true to the spirit of everyone's
favorite regenerating degenerate
Deadpool - doesn't hold back on the
violence profanity and fourth wall
breaks taking everything great about the
first movie and turning it up to 11 in
that vein
Deadpool - also introduced a ton of new
characters and then well let's just say
there are plenty of spoilers ahead some
of these new characters carry a lot of
weight in the comics and a few have even
saved the world once or twice let's take
a look at all the characters in Deadpool
- who mean more than you realized
zeitgeist a lot of hype was given to all
the new mutants debuting in Deadpool -
then the movie came out and dispatched
them all in horrible ways before they
even got to their first mission which is
a shame because some of those characters
have insane stories in the comics take
zeitgeist played in the film by Bill
skarsgård once upon a time he was
actually the leader of one incarnation
of the x-force boy were they weird after
115 generally solid issues of x-force
the series took a bizarre left turn as
issue number 116 opens a drunk
fourteen-year-old vomits acid all over a
girl's face when he tries to kiss her
flash forward in time and he's zeitgeist
the leader of a new x-force they all
seem to be drunk most of the time at
least when they're not groping each
other or doing drugs figuring the team
needs a little good press
zeitgeist hires a group of terrorists to
kidnap a pop band called Boyz R Us
x-force teleports to the scene and
obliterates all the bad guys and then
zeitgeist and most of the team get cut
to pieces and die the end is it a weird
chapter in x-force's history books oh
you bet but somehow zeitgeist feels
exactly like the right type of person to
add to a Deadpool movie and technically
they followed his story pretty closely
all the way to the woodchipper end
bedlam ever since his first introduction
is bedlam and the pages of x-force
number 82 Jessie Aronson has been one of
the core members of the crime-fighting
team as a mutant with the ability to
influence electronics through his own
bio electric field bedlam definitely
played a pivotal role in several
missions and like he says in the movie
he really can directly affect people's
brains which came in handy when the
citizens of San Francisco were turned
into brainwashed
bees and bedlam was able to reverse the
brainwashing without destroying them all
but once upon the time bedlam almost
destroyed the planet in x-force number
87 bedlam left the x-force to join up
with his long-lost brother Christopher
on a team called the new hellions bedlam
later finds out that in a series of jerk
moves Christopher had killed their
parents 14 years earlier and was now
planning to revive a mutant named
Armageddon man with the power to sweep
the world with natural disasters in
other words it was a bad family reunion
realizing the error of his ways
bedlam rejoins x-force to put a stop to
Armageddon man and they all learn a
valuable lesson about friendship
Vanisher you don't see a lot of banasur
in deadpool 2 which makes Brad Pitt's
eventual cameo all the more shocking the
Vanisher of the comics is much different
than the one we see or rather don't see
in the movie first gracing the pages of
uncanny x-men number two the Vanisher
was one of the OG x-men foes a
teleporting mutants who like to rob
banks and steal government secrets
decades later Vanisher was still living
a life of crime when x-force tracked him
down gave him a brain tumor and forced
him to teleport them around to their
battles essentially turning him into
their indentured slave in a long career
filled with dark moments this was
definitely one of the x-force's darkest
and it proved that they were willing to
go to any lengths to get a job done now
under deadpool likes them so much black
Tom Cassidy black Tom Cassidy's biggest
contribution in Deadpool 2 is giving
Deadpool an excuse to grief Gaye below
for who he chooses to shoot but in the
comics he has a much bigger role black
Tom is a mutant infected with the same
techno-organic virus that affects cable
just like in the movie black Tom was
incarcerated at the same prison as
juggernaut and he was also shot by cable
here's where the two paths diverged
however in the comics after cable shoots
him black Tom gets healed and gains the
ability to control plants because why
not and also gains Deadpool's healing
factor
exactly the kind of villain that could
come back to haunt Deadpool especially
if another Deadpool movie takes up the
recent adventures theme of everything we
do has consequences
but maybe without the plan thing that
might be too weird even by Deadpool
standards Russell
since Deadpool - basically served as the
origin story for Russell Collins aka
fire fist it made sure to hit some of
the characters notes from the comics
fire fists origin story saw him as a
Navy recruit who suddenly discovers his
fiery powers gets locked up and breaks
free x-factor shows up to fight him then
lets him join the team and then in the
events leading up to x-force number 24
Russell is imprisoned by a mutant hating
group called the Friends of humanity
leaving the x-force to mount a rescue
operation while he's in transit pretty
much what happened in Deadpool - but
with fewer crotches landing on cables
face but his biggest contributions to
x-force have been well giving them
something to fight not once but twice
has he been brainwashed and turned to
the dark side in the comics once for
every finger he can give we're not sure
where his character will go in any
upcoming films but one thing's for sure
they sure picked a hell of a kid to
rescue Domino when you break it right
down Domino has some of the most useful
powers in the whole film and she's used
them plenty of times in the comics to
get both Deadpool and cable out of tight
spots she also gets one of the coolest
sequences in the movie when she wants to
she could even get the best of Deadpool
with just a few well-timed words which
makes her one of the most formidable
mutants on the team any future Deadpool
film is bound to feature a ton of Domino
showing off how powerful she really is
and despite what Deadpool may say about
it that's a pretty useful ability yes it
is let's meet in the middle and say no
it isn't Hope Summers leave it to
Deadpool to introduce one of the most
powerful mutants in the world and then
end her brief story so tragically we're
talking about hope summers of course
cable's daughter and the whole reason he
traveled back in time in the first place
in the comics hope is what's known as an
omega-level mutant basically just
unstoppably powerful after Cyclops
becomes Dark Phoenix and Avengers vs.
x-men number 11 hope harnesses the
Phoenix force to become an
even more powerful Phoenix and stop it
and an uncanny x-men number 541 hope
absorbs all of the x-men's powers to put
a stop to an out-of-control juggernaut
where does it end well in x-men legacy
number 263 she admits that she's never
seen the true limits of her powers
now that cabl has successfully stopped
her death hope summers could have a big
role to play in whatever on-screen form
the x-force takes next Yukio and Shatter
star in the film shatter star is a
sword-wielding mutants from mojo world
in the comics he's also a sword-wielding
mutant for mojo world along with some
extra weirdness that made him his own
dad's father but that's not where we're
going here after a long history in the
comics x-factor number 45 had shatter
star come out as gay and featured a
panel of him and fellow male mutants
Richter locking lips the Internet was
quick to praise the writers of Deadpool
- for featuring a gay superhero but now
that the movie is out and the only thing
shadows are shattered were some
helicopter blades all the attention in
that arena falls on Yukio who is now in
an on-screen relationship with negasonic
teenage warhead while Marvel movies have
technically featured LGBTQ characters
before Deadpool - puts that
representation right in the forefront
but only after making everyone think
that it was going to come from somewhere
else that's pure Deadpool thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]